Here's the only place where quotes are handled. Tag is always false.
This condition: if we see a quote and tag, then only we should go into quote mode,
it should actually never hold. But maybe there's something wrong with this condition.
So let's come up with the new hypothesis.
A new hypothesis is the error is due to the quote condition evaluating to true.
Let's come up with an experiment to verify this hypothesis.
If this condition evaluates to true, then the next line should be executed.
So what we do is, we simply write an assert false in here,
meaning that the assertion should now automatically fail, if this ever gets executed.
So this piece of code should actually never be reached when executing the program.
Our expectation this time is, with this input, this assertion should fail.
Again, we make this quiz: after we inserted assert false,
does the program now raise an exception meaning that the quote condition holds,
and therefore, something's wrong with that condition
or is the output still foo, that is the input with the quote strip,
and then the quote condition obviously does not hold because the assert false is never reached?
Try this out for yourself.